qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens
moi j'habite q paris donc en fait je me
rends compte en tant qu'usagers de temps
en temps à chaque fois que je monte dans
le métro dans l'eure il ya toujours une
galère d'accord il retrait ils en
pensent quoi non plus je lève une
connerie tu fais un peu différente à
pied cinq courses à pied [ __ ] en
italie par exemple à turin parce que je
suis italienne
il n'y a pas des transports comme ça et
votre faim l'on pense quoi ciao bella
ragazza jérémy à la cote à totti
flottille
qu'est ce qu'on pense et des transports
en commun parisiens franchement j'ai
jamais eu de souci pour l'instant donc
moi ça me va et qu'est ce que vos
friends enfance derrière vous baddou
finalement parce que c'est vrai que
c'est quoi 25 années combat c'est qu'ils
ou elles se perdent
pour les heures de pointe c'est comme a
dit l'un
et votre frère et l'entente soit concret
si tu préfères j'ai pas essentiellement
à l'iufm et c'est vrai que bon on a pas
grand chose à rajouter de plus quoi
c'est certain moussa cheese écoles faire
phoque hanouna et tout le monde est là
la mission le même mois un besoin dès
maintenant nous sommes pas si tu auras
là qu'est ce que vous pensez des
précommandes parisien les trains
supprimés
dix minutes de retard trop de monde ils
se foutent vraiment de notre gueule
heureusement que le pass navigo cinq
zones a b c sinon sinon il m'aurait
trouvé sur leur voie j'en ai marre je
vois de frais l'on conçoit mais il a mal
à ses transports en commun son frère
vous imaginez bien c'est insupportable
on est tous les côtés toute la famille
est révolté on se connait non